[Música]
la ficción es una herramienta poderosa
a lo largo de la historia y aún hoy está
utilizado como una tecnología una
tecnología blanda
el martillo que es una tecnología dura
cumple una serie de objetivos y funciona
de unas determinadas maneras las
tecnologías blandas funcionan de la
misma manera cumplen objetivos concretos
y funcionan de maneras concretas
pensemos por ejemplo en la escucha la
escucha puede ser utilizada como una
tecnología blanda
cuando vemos una entrevista miramos al
periodista o la periodista y vemos que
va sintiendo que va mirando con atención
va per formando esa escucha con algo que
es intangible porque las tecnologías
blandas son intangibles está provocando
una serie de actitudes y una serie de
motivaciones en la persona y de eso es
de lo que se trata en las tecnologías
blandas
entonces cómo es que la ficción se puede
utilizar como una tecnología blanda a lo
largo de la historia por ejemplo hemos
visto como la ficción ha servido para
transmitir información
en los mitos en la antigua grecia la
gente miraba las estrellas y tenían
miedo de que cayeran la ciencia todavía
no estaba tan avanzada como está hoy y
entonces a través de los mitos a través
de estas ficciones a las personas les
explicaba una historia que les daba una
explicación a eso que no podían entender
en la biblia por ejemplo en el génesis
se nos explica cómo se formó el mundo
como aparecieron los primeros habitantes
en la tierra como fueron expulsados del
paraíso y aparecieron nuestras primeras
civilizaciones en estas historias se
narran gestas de gente que hacía
milagros había nueve héroes y habían
villanos estas historias estas ficciones
que se cuentan en la biblia han sido
utilizadas por la iglesia como una
manera de generar una manera común de
entender el mundo una serie de reglas y
en torno a estas reglas se han generado
centenares de comunidades en todo el
mundo
sin embargo en estas historias también
se nos cuentan
hay historias donde la gente peca y paga
por sus pecados es castigada y es aquí
donde la ficción enseña los dientes
cuando en las historias de la biblia se
nos cuenta que hay cosas que son
correctas y hay cosas que son
incorrectas que las cosas buenas son
recompensadas y las cosas malas son
castigadas la ficción lo que está
haciendo es darnos una serie de marcos
de interpretación de nuestro propio
comportamiento está guiando la manera en
la que nos relacionamos en el mundo y es
así como la ficción se convierte en un
instrumento de perpetuación del poder en
una herramienta que disciplina y ordena
la sociedad y es aquí donde la ficción
aparece como algo que genera una
realidad cambia de ámbito pero no
tenemos que irnos tan lejos para
encontrar ejemplos de este tipo las
películas de disney por ejemplo las de
hace 20 años por su por suerte las de
ahora ya han cambiado un poco
bueno pues nos encontramos con
protagonistas femeninas princesas que
son bellas que son dulces que son
inocentes y que están indefensas luego
nos encontramos a hombres aguerridos
valientes fuertes nobles guapos que van
a salvar a esta chica a esta mujer que
está indefensa cuando estas ficciones se
vuelven masivas como se han vuelto este
tipo de ficciones lo que sucede es que
se convierten en parámetros a la hora de
entender la realidad cuando pensamos en
mujer
pensamos en princesa nos da un marco de
interpretación y cuando pensamos en
hombre pensamos en este tipo de hombre
que nos representa y ahí de nuevo la
ficción está creando una manera de
sentirse hombre o de sentirse mujer con
la que seguramente muchos de nosotros y
nosotras no estaremos de acuerdo
las ficciones no están solo en los
libros o en las películas
de hecho tenemos una relación mucho más
cotidiana de lo que nos pensamos con la
ficción cuando hacemos alguna
anticipación cuando pensamos que
queremos hacer algo cuando las
vacaciones por ejemplo no nos queremos
ir a brasil entonces nos imaginamos en
copacabana paseando por las calles de
río conociendo gente
no sirviendo música y entonces empezamos
a hacernos una idea de algo que nos
gusta pero esta idea a futuro es algo
que no existe es una ficción pero que
provoca esta ficción si tenemos los
medios para hacerlo que movilicemos los
recursos en el presente que ahorremos
que nos compremos el billete de avión
que nos coordinemos con los amigos o
planificamos el viaje para poder
convertir esta ficción en una realidad
aquí de nuevo la ficción tiene una
incidencia clarísima en la realidad
esto es una ficción que proyectamos pues
nosotros con nuestros colegas nuestras
familias o nuestras nuestras parejas qué
pasa con los futuros en los que todos y
todos estamos involucrados estos futuros
que nos dicen que van a suceder sí o sí
quien los hace con qué objetivos qué
medios cómo nos llegan
nos han enseñado a pensar que en el en
el futuro habrá un rol central de la
tecnología y esto es lo que hemos visto
en las películas y en los libros
entonces en el futuro equivale a
tecnología es así como nos han enseñado
a ver el futuro ahora
como se vincula la tecnología la
tecnología que utilizamos en el día a
día con la ficción
quizás la manera más fácil de acercarnos
a esta aproximación es pensar en la
ciencia ficción en las novelas de julio
verne por ejemplo en sus novelas en sus
ficciones en sus historias aparecieron
los primeros submarinos o los primeros
helicópteros y estas ficciones
inspiraron a inventores y equipos de
desarrollo a que construyeron a que
materializarán estas ficciones a que
convirtieran estas ficciones en objetos
en medios de comunicación que hoy que
hoy conocemos
y aquí es donde aparece la pregunta que
estoy explorando hoy como la ficción se
utiliza como herramienta a la hora de
generar innovación desarrollo y
aceptación cultural y social de
determinadas tecnologías
pero lo que me interesa realmente no es
como la ficción inspira el desarrollo de
tecnologías sino como la ficción se
utiliza como herramienta para generar
una serie de contextos sociales y
culturales que nos harán abrazar
determinadas tecnologías que están
creadas por unas corporaciones muy
poderosas que tienen unos intereses muy
concretos que en general son hacer mucho
dinero pero van mucho más allá estas
intenciones
lo que hacen con estos futuros lo que
hacen estas ficciones estas empresas es
hacernos abrazar futuros que quizá no
queramos abrazar
constantemente constantemente vemos
vídeos en el día a día la televisión en
internet leemos noticias que nos hablan
de tecnologías que lo van a revolucionar
todo
qué pasa
bueno por un lado tenemos estas
ficciones que nos llegan por otro lado
tenemos estas charlas estas conferencias
en las que los grandes directores de
estas grandes empresas nos hablan de the
next big thing la siguiente gran cosa
pero como pueden saber cuál es la
siguiente gran cosa no se puede saber lo
que nos están contando es una ficción lo
que pasa que esta ficción se nos acerca
como si fuera una realidad
hace algunos años trabajé como
periodista de arte ciencia y tecnología
y en esa época se está empezando a
hablar del internet de las cosas de
estos sensores que se conectan a todos
los objetos recogen información se
conectan a internet y entre ellas y
generan alguna interactividad como es
una tecnología que es muy compleja de
entender bueno me fui a buscar un
informe a una de estas a una de estas
empresas y me encontré con una serie de
detalles técnicos que no termina de
entender pero me encuentre también con
una historia vamos a llamar al
protagonista de esta historia stuart
stuart es un hombre de negocios no es
casualidad que sea un hombre de negocios
el protagonista de esta historia
que tenía una reunión importante a las 9
de la mañana donde tenía la reunión
tardaba una hora en llegar en coche
entonces él se va a dormir en un
escenario de todo está conectado y
mientras está durmiendo en la carretera
hay un accidente este accidente impide
que el por la mañana pueda llegar al
tiempo en el trabajo pero como su móvil
está conectado a todo este entorno de
objetos inteligentes lo que hace es
decir voy a recalcular la ruta voy a ver
que tardaba a tener que tardar un poco
más para llegar al trabajo en hora así
que le voy a adelantar el despertador
para que pueda llegar en el momento en
el que tiene que llegar y esto es lo que
sucede
esta es una historia de ciencia ficción
corporativa de baja frecuencia y con
final feliz la industria silicon valley
como constantemente está inventando
nuevas tecnologías utiliza a discreción
la ficción como una tecnología blanda
para por un lado hacernos entender
cuáles son los contextos con los que nos
podemos encontrar en el futuro
hacen inteligible aquello que nos es
difícil de entender del mismo modo que
los griegos explicaban historias para
que la gente no tuviera miedo de que
cayeran las estrellas también generan un
horizonte de posibilidad de posibilidad
nos dicen bueno pues si todo está
conectado pueden pasar estas cosas
también lo que hacen y esto me parece
especialmente interesante es explicarnos
qué
nos vamos a relacionar de la tecnología
de una manera diferente en este contexto
stuart confía completamente en todos
estos dispositivos conectados y no
tienen ningún miedo de lo que van a
pasar de lo que va a pasar con los datos
o qué va a pasar si alguno de estos
objetos se equivocan
y quizá lo más importante es que estos
escenarios crean un contexto seductor
para que empresas gobiernos
desarrolladores etcétera movilicen sus
recursos en el presente para acercar
este este futuro que les parece
atractivo y de esta manera es como la
ficción
empieza a generar una realidad
hay que tener cuidado con estas
ficciones porque en general nos muestran
un mundo más ideal de más ideal de lo
que es en esta historia no hay un uso de
los datos que termina alimentando la
campaña presidencial de un presidente
fascista en los eeuu o no nos hablan de
hackers rusos tampoco
esto por un lado por otro lado y aquí es
donde el poder de la ficción como
tecnología blanda se vuelve insidioso es
que estas ficciones no nos llegan por
los mismos caminos que nos llegan a las
películas o las novelas que sabemos que
son ficción sino que nos llegan a través
de programas de internet de documentales
o de de la prensa
claro cuando nos llegan estas ficciones
a través de estos canales nosotros las
tomamos como algo que es verdad y es ahí
donde las ficciones se vuelven realmente
poderosas porque son capaces de crear
una ilusión de realidad
una ilusión de realidad que no es
inocente como decíamos es la ilusión de
realidad que es es muy práctica estas
empresas que buscan tener cada vez más
poder y cada vez más dinero
aquí es donde las las ficciones se
vuelven una herramienta política una
herramienta de perpetuación del poder de
estas empresas no solo sobre el presente
sino sobre el futuro en el que nosotros
nos proyectamos y en el que nosotros de
momento no estamos interviniendo
tenemos que estar atentos las ficciones
por un lado pueden servir para crear
comunidad pueden servir para entender lo
que no somos capaces de entender
pueden darnos un marco de comprensión
hacia aquello que es desconocido aquello
que tiene porvenir que tiene que venir
las ficciones como decía nos convencen
de que tenemos que aceptar determinados
futuros y que de que no tenemos poder
sobre ellos y además estas ficciones
cuando se utilizan como tecnología
blanda lo que hacen es lubricar
facilitar el tránsito de una realidad lo
que es hoy algo que podría ser que es el
deseo de estas grandes corporaciones
frente a estas ilusiones lo que tenemos
que hacer primero de todo es aprender a
identificarlas afinar nuestra mirada y
decir esto es una ficción y esto es una
realidad una vez hayas las hayamos
identificado
tenemos que pensar quién nos lo está
contando cómo nos lo está contando qué
sucede en esta ficción y lo más
importante cuáles son los intereses que
hay detrás de estas ficciones estos
intereses ocultos
tomando conciencia de estas ficciones
quizás tengamos la capacidad de generar
herramientas sino para oponernos por lo
menos para identificar y entender los
mecanismos que utilizan estos agentes
tan poderosos para modificar el futuro y
el camino que tenemos por delante esto
por un lado y por el otro
quizás quizás podemos utilizar nosotros
las ficciones como una tecnología blanda
a la hora de imaginar otros presentes y
otros futuros podemos utilizar el poder
de la ficción la apertura de la ficción
para imaginar escenarios sin lass sin
las presiones de gobiernos empresas y
otros actores que generan un mundo
profundamente desigual y discriminador
quizás proyectando estos futuros a
través de la ficción seamos capaces de
movilizar en el presente los recursos
para llegar a un mañana que sea más
vivible para todos y para todas muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]